I was lying under the little straw hut
on sand that felt like thick brown sugar
with my eyes gliding over the waves that
made the sea uninviting it felt like a
storm was coming little did I know that
later that day a thunderstorm with
whizzed through my mind uprooting my
beliefs on what the world should look
like I just finished a consulting
project in Accra Ghana and was on what
felt like a deserving holiday in a
little fishing village a remote little
town of the west coast of Africa I met a
girl called Akua that day with her thick
black camel eyelashes an extremely
expressive face she charmed me and
convinced me to read to her a classic
piece of literature I've been reading
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo I read
out a phrase one by one and she would
repeat she had a little sister on her
back and when she started crying Ikuo
would go her and sing her a song and
come back to reading we did this for a
week every day until the sunset and it
was too dark to read anymore when I was
leaving the town I asked Akua where and
when she went to school she just simply
took her head she was nine years old I
left her with the book but most likely
should I had to wait until a random
travel like me happen to come along to
her to read to her can you imagine a
world where you had to rely on a random
encounter to satisfy a man's curiosity
if this room were represented of the
world you you you you you you and five
more view would not be sitting here in
this room because you would not be able
to read or write as you would have been
denied access to schooling
what I did not tell you about kuwa is
that all four of our brothers actually
went to school because the family could
not afford schooling for all their
children the boys went to school or the
girls stayed home girls education
matters imagine if this room was
represented of the world eight of the 12
people who cannot read and write in this
room will be women and for those of you
who for those of the men out there who
complain about the gender ratios in this
room you know exactly what this means it
means less girls in classrooms girls
education matters every day I sit in
that seat in class and I feel grateful
to be one of the women who can read and
write I think of a core I also think of
my grandmother my grandmother was born
into a generation where women at most
went to finishing school in the
aftermath of the Korean War and had a
stable married life at their utmost
virtue instead she went to university
demanded a divorce from her philandering
husband and wait raised three children
over could she have done this without
the education she received could I be
standing here talking about my
grandmother without Heinz dealing in my
dad the value of educating girls would
you visiting here in this very room
without your parents investing into your
future girls education matters every
child is born equal and every girl or
boy must have exactly the same dreams as
you and I do and they have the right to
realize their dreams yet that you don't
know what you what you can dream of if
you don't know what you could be
dreaming about whether that being a tech
billionaire or changing the world the
coolers of this world dream of heavens
embroidered cloths yet the dreams are
traded on by the family chores attitudes
to women schooling and unaffordable
basic education into
the United Nations declared that by 2015
everyone should have access to universal
basic education yet here we are in 2014
a year to go in a world where one in
five girls do not get basic schooling we
cannot leave occurs and millions of
others dreams to chance girls education
matters and it's not just a right that
they have it matters so much to her cell
own cells of steph's own sense of
self-worth as she earns twenty percent
more for every year she stays in primary
school and to her health as she is three
times less likely to contract HIV if she
finishes primary schooling it's also
been shown that the girls education
touches so many more lives than just her
own can you imagine a world where you
could have the number of children who
die before the age of five and double
the number of children in primary school
or you can help do that by facilitating
women's education educating girls is
like educating future generations like
me and you like the way my great
grandfather and my grandmother did and
it's educating your sisters your
daughter's fifty a hundred and a
thousand years later as they continue to
dream on exactly the way you and I do so
what can you do at this point you're
probably thinking he's ray is going to
ask to donate money well if you'd really
like to do that only takes that in
dollars a year to keep a girl in primary
school but my call to you is even easier
than that I'll ask you two to three
things you can think you can endorse and
you can support they only all take a
moment first thing you can do is think
through how here at the heart of Silicon
Valley you can help women's education
take a moment to see how the new
technologies and the business models can
be applied to delivery of basic
education
beyond and above MOOCs and online
learning second thing you can do is to
endorse education for all art education
for all apt commit the u.s. to invest
its foreign aid to the goal of universal
primary education see if your
representative is a co-sponsor of this
act and if not take a moment to pick
your phone up the thing you can do is to
support and grow a woman's business a
mother's income is so much more likely
to flow through the children and the
family as she feeds her children and
send them to school so take a moment to
donate to organizations like Brock or
spark to advance economic empowerment of
women guard education matters imagine a
world where all the world's occurs could
be talking not which random encounter
help them to read but which book they
like the best which company offer them
equal pay of course I hope that her
favorite book is not the stieg larsson's
trilogy but I do hope that she has a
best book to read girls education
matters someone needs to care deeply to
make this change happen and that someone
should be us we all need to teach the
value of education for all now is the
time to take a moment because if we can
care about equality in the boardroom you
can also care by equality in the
classroom now is the moment to take now
is the time to take the moment because
we cannot leave a girl's dreams to the
whim of a chance encounter now is the
time to take that moment because the
girls education matters me and it should
matter to you thank you
you